nous sommes à l'antenne du secours
catholique de talent face à deux
bénévoles une jeune femme kosovar qui
veut faire des progrès en français est
venu demander un petit coup de main et
déjà vous allez avoir un premier rendez
vous pour un bilan non c'est ça voir où
vous en êtes quel niveau vous avez et
après vous savez tous les jours pour
travailler le français voilà et c'est
pour ça que vous venez nous voir parce
que vous avez des difficultés pour payer
votre transport de talent à dijon
l'antenne de talent a déjà accueilli 220
personnes depuis janvier
elle enregistre les mêmes grandes
tendances qu'au niveau national la
précarité y présentent souvent un visage
féminin femmes seules ou mères isolées
constitue 56 % des adultes rencontrés
mais d'autres catégories viennent
désormais grossir les rangs de la
pauvreté nous avons aussi et ça on le
disait déjà l'année dernière et sa
demeure pour cette année une
augmentation des moins de 25 ans et
d'hommes seuls ça c'était plutôt pour
l'année dernière aujourd'hui on a
toujours ça mais en plus on aime
beaucoup de personnes depuis 30 ans qui
viennent frapper à notre porte
précarité des jeunes d'une part
précarité des anciens d'autre part les
données du secours catholique montre une
évolution inquiétante d'autant qu'ici on
parle vraiment de pauvreté des personnes
qui sont au dessous du seuil de pauvreté
et au dessous de la moitié de ce seuil
de pauvreté ça veut dire ça 140 euros
par mois en gros donc notre population
sait ce seul là et au dessous et un
certain nombre à peu près 50% qui n'a
qu'à 0 inquiétant également ce qu'on
nomme le non recours au droit
un quart des ménages éligibles aux
allocations familiales ne les perçoivent
pas